big tv news tonight matt james makes his
debut as the first ever
african-american bachelor now lauren
zema let's hope
his journey is a little less turbulent
than that of pete weber
yeah kevin i think matt hopes that too
especially because pilot pete and his
girlfriend kelly flanagan
just announced their breakup on new
year's eve a source tells us one of the
couple's
major issues was pete's very involved
mother
barb at 2020 had to get in one more
heartbreak but that is okay because it
is 2021 and matt james is joining me now
to make everything better
it's time for roses and roses
what kind of pressure did you feel
taking on this role and where was it
coming from if any
i thought a lot you know i'm not gonna
lie what i'm looking for
isn't specific to a race and that's why
i was extremely excited about the group
of women that i saw
you know it represented everybody and
that's what i was looking for we have an
exclusive sneak peek of
kylie who meets you in lingerie on night
one
oh man you're seeing women come out of
limos and i see
this drop dead gorgeous woman come up
with
i'm like wait dang i like that a lot
damn
we see you crying on the curb with chris
harrison in this promo you're crying
you okay no there's things in my
personal life
that i try to avoid which are
uncomfortable conversations
so when you have to address those things
that have held you back and
relationships past
that type of emotion comes out and we
all came out better people
and you were shirtless plenty matt and
did you mind because i don't think the
audience is going to complain
it was great weather up there so i
didn't mind you know i got a little tan
all right matt james thank you so much
for joining us